remembering one of rock music's most
bombastic stars welcome to entertainment
tonight you know meatloaf sold over 100
million albums worldwide but he was also
an actor husband and father whose legacy
is still making noise for all to hear
[Music]
i'll give you everything i have if i'm
on stage it's 110 percent
and
when i die
i know
that everything i've ever done
has been full out
[Music]
this was meatloaf's last public
performance it was in march of last year
and his good friend country star john
rich was at his side
i mean you talk about one of the
greatest entertainers of all time i
actually took him down to my bar
downtown in nashville i had my band come
in and play meatloaf songs to meatloaf
how did he react to that
he cried
really
he cried he was a crier
the 74 year old passed away with his
wife deborah by his side and in the
final 24 hours his daughters pearl and
amanda held vigil according to one
report he had been sick with covet 19.
in 2016 meatloaf collapsed at a concert
in canada due to dehydration and he had
a long history of back problems i fell
off the stage in dallas and i was in the
hospital for 31 days
and
i've had four back surgeries i'm just
one of those kind of guys you know rough
and tumble kind of texas boy
e.t spent a lot of time with the rock
star over the last 35 years hi kids how
are you we're in the regional hotel in
london england where are you
[Music]
in 1993 he took us on tour with him and
in his last e.t interview the singer
whose real name is marvin lee aday
explained how he got his nickname that
came in the eighth grade
playing football in junior high school
and i stepped on the coach's foot and he
screamed get off my foot you hunk a
meatloaf
[Music]
that man will never be duplicated never
be replicated he came on my show called
the pursuit which is about people that
pursue happiness in america think about
this story a guy that never gave up you
know he was still working on a new
record at 74 years old meatloaf also
starred in more than 60 movies including
wayne's world
party on
and fight club first rule is
i'm not supposed to talk about it film's
incredible it's the third time i've seen
it it gets better every time
of course his biggest role was playing
eddie in 1975's the rocky horror picture
show alongside tim curry they first
meant starring in the play
tim curry came in and i'm looking and
i'm going what kind of show am i in but
i thought the
music was real roots of rock and roll
i was real happy with it cut to 2016
adam lambert took over meatloaf's role
on fox's reimagining
adam you were fantastic he actually went
on record and said some really nice
stuff about me and i'd love to kind of
say thank you today the idol alum
tweeted you were so kind your music will
always be iconic i'm sure you're singing
concerts in the great beyond
[Music]
two years after rocky horror meatloaf
released battle of hell which was his
first solo album and became his biggest
selling record ever
got a text at 2 40 this morning
andy you all these things just flood
back today we spoke with his paradise by
the dashboard light collaborator ellen
foley what do you remember the most
about recording that song i guess the
way we did it i dragged him into the
room and made him stand there so i sang
it eye to eye with him and i did it once
and that was it one take wonder 60
million records later have been sold is
there something that his fans the
audience might be surprised to learn he
was very lonely he had a separation
anxiety you know because his mother died
young
and needed a lot of love
and
certainly got it from his fans
in 2019 battle of hell became a broadway
show and e.t was exclusively there as
meatloaf surprised a packed theater
loving every minute of it i cried and i
i know these songs really well i cried
three times tonight
the reviews were stellar but ever modest
meatloaf never tried to take the
spotlight
[Music]
i'm not a star i'm not a celebrity i'm
not a legend and i'm not an icon and i
will never let anybody call me that it's
meatloaf and his unbelievable band the
best man in the world are going to be in
your town
[Music]
you